I got to go to Las Vegas this past
weekend to see a banner like the Black
Keys playing but I went out to dinner
with a bunch of friends to this rat this
restaurant that like focuses on meat you
know and it's like one of those like you
know we serve we use the whole pig you
know tip to taint or whatever the
expression is there's no restaurant
that's logo is hip to taint in the
history of restaurants if there's a huge
organic food movement balls to mouth
right I guess I've been going wrong
[Laughter]
anyway sorry I had any meat in awhile I
got meat sweats you ever get meat sweats
I don't know I don't I don't get me oh
I've had meat sweats yeah it's like when
you when you're sweating like the meat
is actually coming out of your pores and
it comes it happens for everybody
differently for me it hits me in my
second chin and you start sweating there
I started sweating on my second chin and
in the back of the inside of my mouth
and and so I was like sweating I was
like oh my god I go to the bathroom so
like ran to the bathroom and I had one
of those businessmen in the in the
airport know like no matter when you're
in the airport if you go to the men's
room there's always like a businessman
in one of the stalls like wearing one of
them or it doesn't matter there's always
a businessman that's like
we don't even know we're all with you
Adam we get it yeah I just don't make
sure everyone knows that I'm talking
yeah we're all right here with you
anyway so so I was doing that and and I
you know clean up as late as I do which
I am NOT hammering Mandela or anything
but I think I do a good job and as you
know as I'm walking out of the bathroom
as I'm walking out of the bathroom I you
know and like that is not that's it's
unusual like take a massive yeah rap and
then fart sure but I was like whatever
you know I'm not judging at this point
yeah so Vegas it's Vegas yeah so yeah
thank you I get to the table I sit down
and my buddy Doug turns to me and he's
like oh my god did you your pants and I
was like that's the dumbest question
I've ever heard I'm coming from the
bathroom like obviously no you saw me
run to the bathroom like I made it I'm
fine I would tell you and then like my
other friends were like no no no this is
not like it's not like that I was like
well I did fart on my way out of the
bathrooms like maybe it traveled like
maybe I I cropped uh stood a little I
don't know like and there and I know
everyone's like no no no this is like an
intense bad smell like this is like
really bad and then the waiter comes
over and drops the check and like I can
tell that he notices the smell like he
notices it and he notices it instantly
like he's putting the check down and
he's like is there anything
[Laughter]
you'll just get me that when you're
ready and like in that silence I was
like oh whoa now I could tell that he
smells my fart from back there since ooh
it's got to be pretty bad and then my
buddy dog is like dude if you if you
your pants don't be embarrassed
just tell us where your friends Oh own
it and I was like dude I didn't and at
that moment I looked down and I saw what
I guess was like between like um a
dollop and a quarter of my own of my own
extra necks of my own duty and I and I
and I and like so I knew that was bad so
uh and I was embarrassed I was I wasn't
I won't you were like it got a story for
code
when life gives you lemons make lemonade
you